I DON’T HAVE IT.
THEY DON’T HAVE IT COME TO SHOCK
THE WORLD AGAIN.
HERE WITH MAURA, SOMEONE WHO
DEALS WITH THE MOB EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
THERE’S NOT ENOUGH MONEY PRINTED
BY THE GOVERNMENT TO ACTUALLY BE
WORTH DOING THIS JOB.
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY IS WITH US.
BY THE WAY I WANTED TO SAY I DID
NOT KNOW THE STORY OF YOUR
PERSONAL STORY THAT YOU SHARED
AT THE CONVENTION.
I WANT TO APPLAUD YOU.
OBVIOUSLY I’M SURE THAT WASN’T
AN EASY THING TO DO.
I AM ALSO CERTAIN THAT YOU
HELPED A LOT OF PEOPLE.
MY MOM SUFFERED, STAGE IV
BREAST CANCER.
SHE SURVIVED IT FAIRLY.
SHE HAS SINCE PASSED AWAY FROM
SOMETHING ELSE BUT I THOUGHT
THAT WAS VERY BRAVE.
I THINK YOU’RE GOING TO HELP A
LOT OF PEOPLE BY DOING THAT.
>> THANK YOU, SEAN.
YOUR MOM WAS A FIGHTER.
WOMEN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ARE
FIGHTERS WHO ARE BATTLING
BREAST CANCER.
IT WAS AN HONOR TO SHARE THE
STORY IN MY HONOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS THE ONE WHO
ENCOURAGED ME TO DO IT.
>> Sean: LET’S TALK.
I WATCH THESE CROWDS.
IT’S NOT JUST KENOSHA,
WISCONSIN.
IT’S EVERYWHERE THE PRESIDENT
GOES.
LINING THE STREETS MILE AFTER
MILE AFTER MILE.
I ACTUALLY HAD A SECRET SOURCE
INSIDE THE MOTORCADE THAT SENT
ME VIDEO THAT I CAN’T AIR.
MILE AFTER MILE.
YOU HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK TO
PEOPLE.
YOU SAW THE REACTION.
KENOSHA WAS SO GLAD THE
PRESIDENT CAME.
VERSUS WHAT THE MEDIA WAS
SAYING, OH, HE CAN’T GO.
HE CAN’T GO.
WELL, HE WENT IN THE HELP
KENOSHA OUT AND RESTORE LAW AND
ORDER THERE.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
OF COURSE THE MEDIA WON’T SHARE
IT BUT WE LITERALLY RODE FOR
15 MILES, SEAN, AND LITERALLY
PERSON AFTER PERSON WAS
PRO-TRUMP.
SHOWING UP, SHOWING THEIR
SUPPORT.
IT’S A DEMOCRAT DISTRICT THAT NO
ONE SINCE RICHARD NIXON HAD WON
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DID WE
ARRIVE AT -- IN KENOSHA, HE
STANDS AT A BUSINESS THAT WAS
BURNED DOWN.
THEY’VE BEEN OPEN FOR 109 YEARS
BUT THEY WERE BURNED DOWN BY
ANTIFA RIOTERS.
AND THEN WE MOVED ON AND WE GO
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT WHERE WE MEET
WITH U.S. MARSHALS, OUR BRAVE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I SAW THIS WOMAN AND SHE WAS A
LITTLE SHY.
I WAS TALKING TO THE U.S.
MARSHALS WHEN I MOVED ON AND I
CAME BACK.
AFTER THE PRESIDENT PASSED
THROUGH, AND THEY WERE -- THERE
IS A WOMAN CRYING, THE SAME
WOMAN WHO WAS A LITTLE SHY AND
NERVOUS.
CROCODILE TEARS.
THEY HAD -- I SAID WHAT
HAPPENED?
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME OVER, SPOKE
TO HER, GAVE HER A LITTLE PIN
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE AND SHE IS
STUNNED, HUMBLED AND HONORED
THAT THIS IS WHAT THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF DID FOR A
WOMAN FROM JACKSON, MISSISSIPPI.
THAT’S THE RESPECT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS FOR OUR MEN AND
WOMEN IN THIS COUNTRY AND I SEE
IT EVERY DAY.
>> Sean: I AM LOOKING AT THIS
VIDEO RIGHT NOW OF ONE OF THE
BURNED OUT BUSINESSES.
I AM LOOKING.
I KNOW FRIENDS THAT HAVE
BUSINESS.
EVERY SINGLE THING THEY HAVE IN
LIFE, THEY USUALLY THROW INTO
THAT BUSINESS, INCLUDING THEIR
HEART, SWEAT EQUITY AND SOUL.
IT GETS BURNED TO THE GROUND.
LOOK, KENOSHA GOT THE HELP.
A LITTLE LATE BUT THEY GOT THE
HELP.
THE PRESIDENT RESTORE LAW AND
ORDER.
THE PRESIDENT DUDA IN D.C.
THE PRESIDENT DID IT IN
MINNESOTA.
HE’S BEEN BEGGING NEW YORK,
CHICAGO, SEATTLE, PORTLAND, L.A.
TO HELP.
THEY KEEP REFUSING TO HELP.
WHY, WHEN PEOPLE’S LIVES ARE
DESTROYED AND PEOPLE ARE DYING?
>> IT’S A GREAT QUESTION.
GOVERNOR EVERS TO HIS CREDIT
FINALLY DID REQUEST THE HELP.
AS WAS SENT TODAY, WHAT IF HE
HAD REQUESTED A 24 HOURS
EARLIER.
THIS BUSINESS THAT HAVE BEEN
OPEN FOR MORE THAN A CENTURY
WOULD STILL BE THERE.
WHAT IF MAYOR WHEELER, THE
DERELICT MIRROR, YOU’RE
RESPONSIBLE ME PORTLAND MISSING
VIOLENCE FOR 100 DAYS HAD
REQUESTED THAT HELP.
THE BEAUTIFUL YOUNG BOY WHO LOST
HIS LIFE IN THE STREETS, A TRUMP
SUPPORTER WHO WAS SOUGHT OUT AND
GUNNED DOWN BY 100% ANTIFA
INDIVIDUAL AND HIS WORDS WOULD
STILL BE HERE.
IT’S LAWLESSNESS AND DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS AND MAYORS NEED TO
STEP IT UP.
>> Sean: I HOPE.
I WANT TO ADVERB I SAID IN THE
BEGINNING.
YOUR ODDS AFTER YOU GOT THIS
TEST, 84% AT SOME POINT IN YOUR
LIFE YOU WOULD HAVE HAD
BREAST CANCER.
I WOULD URGE WOMEN.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT THE.